there's a lot to be concerned about
right now when it comes to a second
Trump term let's continue with Jen saki
because now she's warning us what evil
Donald Trump might do if he gets that
second term and yet the hand ringing and
cocktail party speculation about an
alternative to Joe Biden is continuing
will continue guess what Joe Biden isn't
perfect no candidate is by the way but
we have to understand what the
alternative is here if elected to a
second term Donald Trump would prosecute
anyone he deems an enemy unleash troops
on protesters and essentially unravel
the rule of law as we know it and this
time he plans to line his administration
with people who will actually help him
do it but sure Joe Biden is three years
older and occasionally trips over things
look there's a lot to be concerned about
right now when it comes to a second
Trump term the speeches are getting much
more disturbing and much more unhinged
and we should all hear it that way by
the way again you guys know I've been
critical of trump I'm not supporting
Trump right now I think there's a much
better choice on the Republican side in
Rhonda STIs I think that's fairly
obvious and I think a lot of people are
going to be shocked in Iowa but this
endless this hand ringing this
fear-mongering this craziness from by
the way a woman who is now thought of as
a journalist on MSNBC who worked for Joe
Biden right she was the press secretary
for Joe Biden and now she's analyzing
the news on MSNBC like the whole thing
is just an
absolute farce but what they fear
actually is not that Donald Trump is
going to jail his political opponents
which is much more in line with what
they would like to do and it's not that
he's going to destroy the other
political party or just whatever the
craziness of the day is with these
people it's not any of that right what
it really is is that he or actually any
Republican might start doing some things
that are a little more pro-america and
these people are not interested in
America